pangolins are a really unique group of
mammals they are covered with these
scales that are made of keratin which is
the same material as human fingernails
and if those scales that are in high
demand and it's driving a lot of the
illegal trade that we see here at the
National Fish and Wildlife forensics
laboratory we're very much like a Police
Crime Lab in that we examine evidence in
a triangular fashion attempt to link
suspect that when the crime lab together
with that evidence we had assist
investigators at the state national
international level who investigate
violators while I'd the bars were the
only such full-service wildlife crime
lab in the world we were very much aware
that penguins have been killed for a
wide range of reasons these little
creatures have a hard time protecting
themselves there are defenses to roll up
into a ball which makes them easily the
poachers to collect Pangolin scales have
been used in traditional medicines and
different parts of the world for a long
time but it's just now that it's on this
larger commercial scale that's where we
see these species being frightened but
then we became aware of this interesting
story that you could grind up a Pangolin
scale and extract chemicals out there to
make the illicit drugs so there was this
rumor on online news resources that
Pangolin scales contain tramadol
tramadol is synthetic analgesic so it's
used to treat pain it's not known to be
synthesized in any natural system and
then there was on top of this even some
suggestion that the trade and pangolins
was driven in part by this demand for
for tramadol which was then being used
for the manufacture of methamphetamine
we weren't really sure to what extent
this kind of rumor was actually driving
the trade but it was something that we
could actually address with the data
that we had and actually look for it we
were asked to identify Pangolin scales
early on simply because they were being
seized as evidence
we actually probed the sample for
tramadol and we did that for a hundred
and four scales representing 104
different individuals of all species
alright so what we do is just go in and
try to find a spot that's minimally
invasive that people aren't going to
notice too much here and we don't need
very much so the dart can can obtain
profiles from really small pieces of
material so the dart is getting the full
chemical profile of that keratin it
gives us in a bit the entire spectrum of
what's in there and we can probe that
chemical profile to look for tramadol
specifically and that's what we did
it's telling you the size and the
intensity of the ions that are actually
in the sample
I came to this lab because I wanted to
do something that I thought could make a
difference we're just doing our small
part to help reduce illegal wildlife
trade we looked at all species and we
didn't find any evidence for tramadol
within our detection window so we're
confident that we didn't find tramadol
we've worked a lot of interesting cases
in which we've examined evidence on
rhino horn pills final horns themselves
sea turtle meat or seat or leather in
the glass eels wide range of wildlife
parts and products but I think the
penguin skills offered us something a
little different I'm happy to think that
our work is going to help stop the
killing of these poor creatures for a
myth for a story that simply isn't true
if that's the case we'll be happy indeed
[Music]